i'm in the kitchen with a true friend of
the show danny sia
okay his new cookbook is called
naturally delicious dinners and is
available everywhere right now i love
this cover and i love
the mission of this book
um tell me and tell us about it
naturally delicious dinners it's
basically yes we can make dinner from
scratch and so this is the best of like
eight years of recipe development we did
at the magazine where it's less than 10
degrees sometimes it's like four or five
ingredients all plant-based and
vegetarian it's fresh but flavorful and
foolproof and it's very economical too
because i know we're talking about ways
to save money
thrifty week and so we're gonna make
something that you can make for an
entire family for about 11
for this entire dinner which is so great
so what we're gonna do here is this is a
version called carrot chipotle sliders
love it and we're roasting this it's so
simple to make and you're going to make
your own
homemade barbecue sauce you can make
your own sauce it's so easy you'll never
buy bottled again after you learn this
recipe i love barbecue sauce and i
cannot wait teach me very first thing we
got here on our this is one tray you can
make this in the oven or in a beautiful
air fryer i will say sheet pan cooking
is fantastic for home cooks who do get
intimidated you put it on you stick it
in the oven it comes out it's different
and it's amazing and it's very
empowering and there's no cleanup
because we're using parchment so on a
parchment line cookie sheet we've got
onions
red cabbage and carrots so take a little
bit of olive oil right here we're going
to drizzle it on a tiny bit of salt
and then you want to massage it just a
little bit deep tissue all right we're
going to deep tissue
by the way if i ever do get the pleasure
of going for a massage i ask them to
treat me
like i'm an animal carcass
and they're a vulture and it would be
preferable if there was no meat on my
bones by the end of it
i don't know i don't think it's a
massage i'm looking for really at the
end of the day
it's like a full-blown
like
i'm just looking for someone to like
crack me reset me and just pummel me
um
[Applause]
no one will beat me apart enough i just
want i'm like
everyone's too gentle go on daddy i'm
just um so they go this goes into the
oven 450 degrees for about 15 minutes
and then you're going to just sort of
mix it all up in another 10 minutes okay
perfect it's cooked all the way through
and what we're going to do in a bowl is
you're going to separate the beautiful
roasted uh cabbage this beautiful deep
color gets here this is our garnish
that's going to go on top and right here
this is our carrot and onion mixture but
we're also going to make
some homemade barbecue yeah that i can't
wait to learn so while this is all
cooking in there in about 10 minutes
we're going to homemade barbecue sauce
it's just tomato paste apple cider
vinegar salt chipotle powder garlic
powder onion powder the nice thing guys
is that a maple syrup you can customize
it so if you want it to be a little bit
sweeter you know you add a little more
sugar to it so this is where as you're
cooking it you can taste it you can
customize you can add things you can add
a little beer if you want to whatever
you want to make your own beautiful
delicious oh my gosh
ooh and it has a kick
this one's spicy
i like the spicy i like food like a
massage i want it to kick my you know i
love spice that's a 46 year old palette
in there that's good doesn't it give it
to me and by the way i just want to
mention i know it's thrifty week when
you're shopping at the supermarket be
sure to shop in your bulk bin section
don't skip that because you can save up
to 80 off um okay so bulk bin 80 percent
off up to 80 off less packaging and you
get exactly what you need but we got to
make our sliders you also told me to
order all of my stuff in bulk so that i
stopped um you know the
fuel and costs of shipping um just put a
little bit of sauce not too much that's
good so we're gonna make them you ready
so you get your little toasted bun
you take your carrot and onion mixture
put it right in the middle because it's
all sticky from that sauce it's all
going to just clump right on there a
little bit of the red cabbage right on
top
i think a little bit more than that
the red cabbage has this beautiful scent
to it from the roast too and look at
this this is actually kind of cute for
halloween don't you think by the way
it's totally halloween color
[Applause]
naturally delicious
[Music]
again
this will be my go-to barbecue sauce
recipe and um you can go to our website
to get this recipe i'm literally going
to go and follow i want to know exactly
how you did this one because i want to
follow it to a tea
and there are delicious vegetarian easy
meals from danny's new book
naturally delicious dinners out
everywhere i'm so excited i have my copy
and danny don't you have an announcement
by the way i'm already starting to dog
here all the recipes i'm gonna attempt
can't return it um what i've done drew
is that i partnered with one of the best
meal delivery companies called sunbasket
they specialize in organic ingredients
and so starting today you can go to
sunbasket.com
and you actually can order these sliders
as a kit so it's all prepared and ready
for you to go with tons of other great
healthy options for you so for all of
you guys
instead of buying a sun basketball i'm
going to give you all
so you can have dinner tonight
[Applause]
thank you okay well um we're gonna do
another segment together that i'm really
excited because you're going to share
some thrifty tips as well as ross and i
don't know about yours because i'm doing
mine and i'm telling you mine is a game
changer not that it's a competition i
don't mean it that way but i'm just
telling you
you're going to want to stick around for
that oh yeah
[Music]